I've pitched this numerous times saying
Jer here here's what happens with Jeremy
boring they tell him 100 times the
market rate to play a song one time was
no good we assume he offered
$150,000 to play one song one time and
they told him no so instead he spends
the money to make a spoof song to B
basically as an Fu we team up with them
doing a modern version for a similar
reason because when we put out our song
we got emails back from entertainment
press saying go f yourself and I'm like
I'm very determined now to force our way
into these charts so they have no choice
but to write about I want to tell you
something else even though three of the
four songs we've published have charted
on Billboard they go into my Wikipedia
page and they remove the chart numbers
to make it look like the songs are not
successful that's how dirty and driven
these people are so buy the song of the
bestsong ever.com and contribute your uh
might to get help us me uh Carter Banks
Jeremy boring and Michael NES give that
middle finger and you'll get a you'll
get a discount